so
that leads me into the youtube channel
which i started
may 24th 2014
right so seems like not that long ago to
me but 2014 was quite a while ago
and the reason why i started up the the
channel and it was called entrepreneurs
and cars for those that don't know is
well i was a guy that was fond of
hanging out with entrepreneurs because
the eo uh slate for me was amazing i had
a great experience with that
but i needed to grow from that and i
also loved fast cars so i decided let's
interview entrepreneurs in their fast
cars entrepreneurs and cars ran out of
friends with cool cars
very quick that were fast started
talking about other stuff in business
how i use lawyers uh how i use parties
to hire people
you know like typical stuff tips and
then that kind of lead into
some other problems that i was dealing
with and i remember there was a um
there was a message one time somebody
said in the comments you got to do a
video on the kind of women to avoid
dating i like all your business tips but
i want to hear your
you know your advice on that and it just
so happened
that i was dealing with the starting
points of the symptoms you know towards
like ptsd and my own and plugging right
and that's when i kind of like
started to talk to other guys and
somebody you know said to me at this
men's retreat i was at uh
um spokane washington at ben
greenfield's house and
this dude in the group were having
breakfast and we're shooting the
and we're just talking about life and
he's like oh you got to read this book
by
this guy rolo tomasi the rational male
and it's it's totally gonna help you
understand everything a lot better i'm
like okay
so download that listen down on the
flight back and boom
all of a sudden i hear and i learned
about this thing called the manosphere
just pouring myself a tea just stand by
fellas
and then i figure oh wow
this is interesting i can see how this
could be useful
there's a lot of things here that help
you know
on f guys so i started talking about
that
and it got a lot of very positive
feedback you know dudes were like
you know what it was i can tell you
exactly what it was everybody
that i've talked to personally that that
knows me well that's coming to my inner
circle
has said the reason why your channel
grew was because you made your wounds
your work
okay you obviously were sincere about
what it is that you were stuck on
and you wanted to unf yourself and as
part of the process you shared those
stories and experiences with other guys
and it was so authentic that it
resonated to help others
understand it too that was the last few
years of my life and here i am
still at it with a regular podcast
series on youtube
these are all by the way uploaded to
podcasts as well so if you want to
listen to before the train wreck on
itunes or
spotify or whatever it's all there my
editor takes care of it
he's cutting up shorts out of it he's
putting it on on on clips channels
and tightening up the uh the content and
then all of a sudden you realize holy
this place is a cesspool
there's a lot of dysfunctional dudes in
this manner swamp
and they can be problematic
you